التطورات الميدانيه في مدينه باخموت
المحاصره اصلا من قبل القوات الروسيه
يتحول الحديث بشانها عن هجوم اوكراني
مرتقب تعد له كييف القياده الاوكرانيه
تقول ان الهجوم ياتي لتقويض تقدم القوات
الروسيه المتعثر منذ اسابيع وفك الحصار عن
المدينه
الكسندر قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
قواتنا ظلت تدافع عن بخموت على مدى اشهر
سنشن قريبا هجوما مضادا ضد القوات الروسيه
الجيش الاوكراني وفي محاوله لتشجيع قواته
على الهجوم المضاد اعلن عن خسائر كبيره في
صفوف الروس مؤكدا مقتل 2020 جنديا روسيا
خلال معارك داريه في لمن وافديكا ومارينكا
وشاختريسكي كما صدت القوات الاوكرانيه نحو
80 هجوما روسيا وما تزال صامد في باخموت
كذلك الرئيس زيلينسكي حذر زعماء الاتحاد
الاوروبي من ان تاخير الدعم العسكري
لقواته ربما سيفتح المجال امام بوتين
لاعاده تنظيم صفوف قواته والاستعداد لحرب
قد تطول لسنوات من جانبها جددت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه على الموقف الاوروبي
الداعمى
الرئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
سنستمر في تقديم ما في وسعنا لاوكرانيا
وزياده دعمنا بالمعدات العسكريه ارحب ايضا
بالاتفاق في مجلس الشؤون الخارجيه لتوفير
مليون طلقه من الذخيره
وامام تعثر تقدم القوات الروسيه في باخموت
تحدثت تقارير غربيه عن تحقيق روسيا لبعض
المكاسب في مناطق شمال اوكرانيا مثل
استعاده السيطره جزئيا على مداخل مدينه
كلميمنا جاسم محسن العربيه